ふぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁ
こんばんは、寝る寸前のはじめしゃちょーです
目が覚めたよ！
目が覚めた！
いひっ
あひっ　あひっ
目が覚めたよ！
あひ～～
目が覚めたよぉ　え...
ちょっと疲れてるみたいですね
はい、というわけで今日はですね、
寝る前なのでちょっと緩くいきましょう
私はじめしゃちょー、23歳
こんな僕にも可愛い時期がありました
今回の動画では僕の子供のころをどんな子だったのかをちょっと、見ていきましょう
どんな風に育って
このような超天さ...
馬鹿が生まれたのか
なんか写真から手がかりがあればいいなと思っております
僕もね、息子ができたらね、僕みたいに天さ...
いい子に育てたいんで、なんか参考になれればいいなと思っております
子供のころからずっと写真撮られてて
それをアルバムにしてるんですよね、思い出アルバム
そのアルバムの中で俺が写ってるやつを全部送れって言って
母ちゃんに送ってもらったんで
僕が子供のころどんな子だったのかなっていうのをちょっと見ていきましょう
はい、一枚目はこれです
あぁ、面影はありますな
幼稚園、保育所か
いつだろう、忘れた
エレクトーンかな、ピアノみたいのをちょっと習ってまして
中３ までピアノっぽいのをやってました
今じゃもう全く弾けないんですけど
なんか週1のレッスンで練習を絶対していかないタイプの生徒だったんで
毎回鬼のように怒られてて
あんまり楽しくなかったです
次！
あぁ～
あっはははは！
髪の毛丸っ！
顔も丸いぞ！このとき
恐竜博物館に多分弟と行ったんですけど
このころからもうちょっとなんか予兆は出てたのかもしれないですね
次！
あっ
これ懐かしいですね
これ、中学校の時です
中学校の時僕、生徒会副会長に立候補しまして
うわぁ俺公約ちゃんと書いてあるな
はっはっはっはっは...
ピンとこねーな
無事当選して、生徒会副会長になりました、ありがとうございます
次！
これは雑でしょ
ってか写真じゃないし
これ多分僕、自分で書いたんですかね
多分自分で書いた選挙ポスターです
んくぁっ
あぁーー！これ可愛いですね
可愛い！可愛い！
可愛らしい、これ多分小学校の入学式とかですね
顔にちょっと、面影がありますな
可愛らしいです
次！
あららら、指がケガしてますね
おねむだったのかもしれないね
ちょっと...
デブってね？
ちょっと丸いね
次！
あぁぁぁ、はじめちゃんどうしちゃったのかな
車がすごい昔好きだったんですよ、ミニカーとか
んで普段ミニカーみたいな多分小さい車しか持たせてられなかったんですけど
このときはじめてこういうなんか
バカでかいタイヤのオフロードカーみたいな車をもらって多分
テンション上がりすぎて...
死にかけてるところです
次！
あぁこれもまた可愛いですね、プールで遊んでますね
右にいるエイリアンみたいなやつは僕の弟です
屈託のない笑顔ですな
次
俺...なんだろう
このころからちょっと中二病発症させてたのか知らないですけど
次！
これは多分生まれた時ですな
うーん
ふはっ
ちょっと待ってや
ちょっと待てや！
アイスクリームがうまく食べれなかったのかな
こんな顔で、こうやって指さしても全然かっこよくないからね
次！
っはっはっはっは
ちょっと待って...
はっはっはっは
ちょっと待ってよー
この笑顔と剣を持っているこの、仕草
昔と変わってねーな
近くに剣があるってとこもまた恥ずかしい
なんかあんまり昔と変わってないのかもしんないね
刀好きなんですよ、刀
次！
これは多分結構最近ですね
高校生の時の写真です
運動会かな、団長をやってたんで
最後、団長がキラキラの衣装着て走らなきゃいけないっていうんですけども
見事に片乳だけでてるっていうね
顔が若いな
ただのほっこり動画になっちゃたんですけど
まぁ、なんだろな
俺は成長しないなぁと思いました
家族には大事にされてここまで育ったので
本当家族には感謝しております、ありがとうございます
っていう感じです、僕の子供のころ
以上、はじめしゃちょーの子供のころの写真でした
ちょっとこっぱずかしい企画だったな
またなんか面白い写真あったら母ちゃんに聞いてみるんで
またひょっとしたら見るかもしれません
じゃあな！